bonjour c'est blaise matuidi pour bruit
merci
dans un groupe bien sûr il ya des
amitiés qui se forge
on n'est pas toujours obligé d'être les
uns sur les autres mais le plus
important c'est que c'est qu'il ya des
moments il ya des moments clés ça soit
sur et en dehors du terrain et ces
moments là et son sont importants ce
groupe laquelle on que qu'elles ont
créés que la cnr la sélectionneuse pas
dans pardon corinne jack a créé ce soit
une femme y voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux leur souhaiter
et surtout qui donne les meilleurs et
après qu'elle nous fasse rêver bien sûr
le plus important c'est prendre du
plaisir et de profiter parce que
honnêtement ça passe tellement vite
l'impression que un mois c'est long mais
au final on se rend compte que c'est
très court quoi on n'a pas le temps on
n'a pas le temps de savourer en fait les
matches s'enchaînent et et
et c'est donc non profit qu'elles
profitent et qu'elle vive qu'elle vive
le moment présent après le talent est
long et surtout qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient soudés qu'elle soit une famille
sentez pousser des ailes et ça nous a ça
nous a énormément aidés
ça doit les emporter en fait ça doit les
emporter le public il est là pour elle
il de la pression que la prose et
pression positive d'être positive cette
pression pour elle
ouais c'est pas évident je repense à
l'euro même si on voulait pas lire la
famille etc
les amis
vous parlez du coup donc je suppose que
c'est pas évident pour elles si elles
peuvent bien sûr éviter éviter dans le
sens où restait quand même concentré sur
sur ce qu'ils ont à faire sur le terrain
et
et elles dans leur groupe c'est le plus
important après
bien sûr que c'est bien c'est super
qu'on parle d'elle et justement on doit
parler du football féminin parce que
parce que c'est beau à voir aussi pour
avoir vu quelques matches c'est
magnifique
j'espère vraiment qu'ils iront occasion
bout ça va pas être facile mais on
espère
c'est vrai que c'est humain après je
pense qu'elles sont elles sont quand
même habitué c'est quand même des
joueuses qui pour la plupart en ont
l'habitude et même si il ya quand même
des jeunes des jeunes jouaient ce qu'ils
sont qui sont arrivés je veux m'adresser
plus haut je ne joue aussi le conseil
que j'ai à leur donner l'on sait c'est
profiter c'est un moment fabuleux une
coupe du monde ça je suis pas forcément
tous les jours donc non je pense que
même si la famille
et et peut parfois vous manqués mais
comme tout le monde sait ça peut parfois
être qu'une fois voir 2 et est encore
dans son pays ça sera qu'une fois donc
vivez ce moment
[Musique]